que georges orellana fondateur du blog
franchise bonsoir monsieur orellana
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt
france cette constitution qui date de
l'ère pinochet était considéré comme
inégalitaire pour quelles raisons c'est
une constitution premièrement qui a été
et qui a été choisi par les dictateurs
avec ces gars de rapprocher il ya eu
aucun processus démocratique que le
chili était un dictature et donc
premièrement c'est une constitution qui
n'a pas de l'égalité réelle puisque elle
a été imposée a montré très douloureux
de l'histoire du chili
et deuxièmement c'est une constitution
qui qui par des pairs avec un système
économique qui a été mis en place au
chili par un groupe qui s'appelle les
chicago boys et qui des vosges dans un
système néolibéral ultra néolibérale qui
laisse la santé l'éducation et les
retraites ou vraiment à la traîne et
donc cette ce référendum aujourd'hui est
un tournant historique pour le pays
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment un robot
unique dans notre histoire
c'est quelque chose qui a été conquise
par par la revue par les manifestations
donc c'est un moment qui va permettre si
vraisemblablement les résultats qu'on
arrive à avoir ses confirme va pouvoir
permettre au peuple chilien dé choisir
sa sa nouvelle constitution de la
rédiger et des l'écrire en des façons
complètement démocratique
oui puisqu'en cas de wii pourront à dire
exactement qui sera chargée de rédiger
cette constitution ça peut ça peut être
avec une partie des députés mais
également avec des gens issus de la
société civile
oui en fait il ya c'est vrai qu'il ya
deux options une qui est pour les
changements des constitutions une
deuxième qui est pour l'une réfute ces
changements et la deuxième question qui
est posée aux électeurs aux 14 millions
d'électeurs qui seront bien sûr non
aujourd'hui au chili c'est desquels
façon souhaitez vous que cette
constitution soit écrite
la première option c'est une convention
mixte donc avec une partie des députés
qui sont actuellement aux élus et une
partie des citoyens et lui parler par
les gens et la deuxième qui est de la
deuxième possibilité c'est de déchoir
une convention constituante c'est à dire
c'est comme une assemblée constituante
élue ou les jo c'est du 100% par les par
le peuple par tout le monde
donc cette commission il serrait et les
libérer au travail pendant 9 mois je
crois pour rédiger cette nouvelle
constitution ce qui a mis à exclure
ainsi c'est cette augmentation du prix
du ticket de métro on s'en souvient il
ya un an ce qui est au coeur l'enjeu en
tout cas de cette nouvelle constitution
c'est la pauvreté au chili qui a été
exacerbée aussi par la crise sanitaire
oui c'est à dire que les gens qui sont
pros le système économique est mis en
place au chili donc du système
néolibéral va vous dire que le chili n'a
jamais connu autant de richesses qu'il
n'y a jamais eu autant de d'étudiants
qui accèdent à l'université etc etc
mais c'est vrai que les inégalités n'ont
jamais été aussi grande
entre ceux qui ont le pouvoir économique
au chili qui dit pouvoir économique dit
pouvoir culturel pouvoir des
consommations ou je lis tout est fait
pour que les gens vivent de façon inde
était et puissent alimenter le système
qui a été mis en place et la gestion de
la crise la crise sanitaire est passée
par là comme partout dans le monde et le
chili est quand même le sixième pays le
plus meurtri par cette crise sanitaire
oui c'est une mine y attendent
il ya je crois que je lisais aujourd'hui
qu'on va arriver presque 500 mille
personnes contagion dont 15000 personnes
décédées c'est vrai que cette pandémie a
mis en évidence la précarité du système
de santé il n'y a presque pas de système
santé publique au chili
donc quand ouais c'est de la crise et
les udc sh et des charges est très
important dans la vie du pays avec des
pertes d'emplois
l'héritage politique de cette
constitution va va également changer on
sait que ce système favorise et
évidemment les conservateurs au pouvoir
ça aussi ça va pouvoir être modifié oui
c'est un c'est l'espoir en tout cas un
connard
là je voudrais vraiment remarqué qu'
aujourd'hui apparemment aux pays bas ça
sert à la l'élection la plus avec la
plus grande affluence et au chili les
votes et volontaire il n'est pas
obligatoire et apparemment d'après
toutes les infos que quand on commence à
recevoir il ya 6 heures
16h59 au chili l'affluence est massive
donc même les jeunes qui ne croyaient
plus dans dance aucun système sont là
pour marquer les points
et dire qu'ils veulent vraiment des
changements profonds et qui ne veulent
plus du système qui les étrangle c'était
la question de ce scrutin évidemment la
participation en plein en pleine crise
sanitaire et de ce que vous en dites en
tout cas la participation serait plutôt
bonne actuellement
oui il faut savoir que les chili ça fait
200 220 jours je suis quoi où il ya le
couvre-feu et où il ya eu un confinement
qui a duré qui a été très très très long
pendant la période d'hiver là on
l'hémisphère sud on commence à arriver
vers l'est vers le printemps et l'été et
les gens non d'équité qu'elle
confinement a été enlevée surtout dans
la région métropolitaine à santiago où
il ya 7 millions de personnes qui vivent
les gens sont sortis manifester et puis
aujourd'hui il ya il ya vraiment une
participation qui est très très très
très importante si ça je crois que ça a
surpris tout le monde
les manifestations vous en parliez ont
dégénéré aussi quelque peu un petit peu
avant ce scrutin
ouais mais je dirais que ça c'est
vraiment la partie la partie chanta stic
de deux
des l'événement qui a lui aussi l'idée
piano il ya toujours des gens qui vont
déborder une manifestation qui vont en
profiter pour casser mais la preuve
qu'aujourd'hui les joues chili sont
allés voter c'est que il tance que c'est
là c'est la bonne voie pour essayer dé
changer les choses et je pense qu'ils
vont rester très très très attentif à
est ce qu'il va se passer par la suite
reconnaître les résultats assez
rapidement selon vous oui je pense que
vers 3 4 heures du matin en france où
l'on peut le voir les résultats merci
beaucoup georges et orellana d'avoir
répondu ce soir
à la question sur arte france bien sûr